[Music]
over 150 moons orbit the solar system's
planets
and one of those moons
calls earth home
the moon was formed about 4.5 billion
years ago when according to one theory
the earth slammed into another early
planet
debris from this collision began to
orbit earth and accumulated forming
today's moon
the moon is the fifth largest natural
satellite in the solar system with a
diameter just under the width of china
it's composed of an iron-rich core plus
a mantle and crust containing minerals
made of magnesium oxygen and silicon
the moon's surface was once geologically
active and covered in an ocean of magma
but today apart from traces of water ice
the surface is completely covered in
dust and rocky debris
countless craters dot the moon's surface
each formed by objects such as
meteoroids comets and asteroids crashing
onto the moon
the largest crater the south pole aitken
basin spans across a quarter of the
moon's surface and is nearly deep enough
to fit mount everest inside
the moon orbits our planet at an average
distance of 30 earths
it rotates at the same rate that it
revolves
so as it revolves around our planet the
same side of the moon faces the earth at
all times
from the earth's surface we can observe
eight distinct traditionally recognized
stages of the moon's illumination
called lunar phases they have been
observed for thousands of years and even
provided the basis for the earliest
calendars
for most of human history the moon could
only be studied from afar
[Music]
but on july 20th 1969
humans were able to close that distance
with the american space flight mission
apollo
11. that's one small step for man
one
diaper
it placed humans on the moon for the
very first time bringing our
understanding of earth's only natural
satellite
one step closer
[Music]
[Music]
foreign